[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild zu den Opfern von Marc drou gehören
die beiden Mädchen Melissa Rousseau und
Julie leugenia beide wurden achtjährig
im Juni 1995 entführt in einem Verlies
festgehalten und sexuell Missbrauch
die Mädchen verhungerten während drou
wegen autodiebställen für dre Monate im
Gefängnis
saß die 19-Jährige fje lambrex und die
17-jährige anmarchall sterben im Jahr
1995 nachdem die Tru und Komplizen sie
entführt missbraucht und gefoltert haben
im Mai 1996 entführt D Trud die damals
zjährige Sabin Dad und im August die
damals 14jährige Letizia D und steckte
sie in sein verließ aufgrund von
Zeugenaussagen kann er dann gefasst
werden die zwei Mädchen kommen frei
Sabin hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt mehr als 70
Tage und Letizia etwa eine Woche im
Verlies verbracht und damit herzlich
Willkommen zu Tatort Deutschland und dem
zweiten Teil dieses unfassbaren falls
des Falls Mark dütru mein Name ist merko
Kasimir und ich bin Tony
haer dieser Fall ist so absurd weil der
fünffache Familienvater durou und seine
Lebensgefährtin Michelle Martin bereits
in den 80er Jahren wegen der Entführung
und des Missbrauchs von Mädchen
verurteilt worden waren selbst seine
Mutter warnte die Behörden davor wie
gefährlich ihr Sohn sei drou sollte
eigentlich 13 Jahre absitzen kam aber
nur 6 Jahre nach seiner Verhaftung wegen
guter Führung wieder frei und 10 Jahre
später ist das wieder D Trus Mutter die
sich nach dem Verschwinden der ersten
beiden Mädchen bei den Behörden meldet
und sagt bitte bitte durchsuchen Sie die
Häuser meines Sohnes ich vermute dass er
der Täter ist aber nichts passiert
wirklich schwer zu glauben aus heutiger
Sicht denn immerhin ist er schon als
Sexualstraftäter vorbestraft und auch
die eigene Mutter warnt vor ihm und
trotzdem reagieren die Behörden nicht
und das ist noch lange nicht die einzige
ermittlungspanne im August
1995 schließt die Polizei endlich Mar
dtru zu observieren und jetzt wird es
richtig absurd die Kamera die sein Haus
in marsinell filmt läuft nur tagsüber
nur von 8R bis 18 Uhr nachts bleibt die
Kamera aus wenn die Kamera auch nachts
gelaufen wäre dann hätte man Marc drou
viel schneller überführen können die
dramatischste und wie ich finde auch
herzzerreißendste Panne die unterläuft
der Polizei im Dezember 19
5 sie durchsuchen eines der Häuser von
Mar Tru weil er in einen Autodiebstahl
verwickelt ist ein Schlosser der bei der
Durchsuchung dabei ist der sagt zum
leitenden Ermittler hören Sie das ich
höre
Kinderstimmen der Polizist sagt nein die
Stimmen kommen von draußen das sind
spielende
Kinder und obwohl der Schlosser sich
sicher ist dass die Stimmen direkt aus
dem Haus kommen da sagt der Beamte
jetzt hören sie auf ich bin hier der
Polizist da ist nichts gehen
wir es ist das Haus in dem zu dem
Zeitpunkt die beiden achtjährigen
Melissa Rousseau und Julie leugenie im
Keller versteckt sind in einem kleinen
Kerker der von außen nicht zu erkennen
ist mit einem Regal Kisten und Gerümpel
vor dem Eingang die beiden kleinen
Kinder versuchen verzweifelt auf sich
aufmerksam zu machen aber vergeblich die
Polizei zieht wieder ab
das heißt auch Melissa und Julie hätten
gerettet werden können und da fragt man
sich schon sind das wirklich nur
Ermittlungsfehler oder wird Mar du Tru
von einflussreichen Leuten in der
Regierung gedeckt er selber sagt im
Verhör er sei nur ein kleiner Teil eines
landesweiten
pädophilennetzwerkes das bis in die
Spitzen der Politik reicht Anhaltspunkte
dafür gibt es genügend so wird z.B
Michelle niul festgenommen ein
Geschäftsmann aus Brüssel der in den
80ern sexparys mit Minderjährigen
veranstaltet hat Partys zu denen
einflussreiche Geschäftsmänner und
Politiker gingen eines der damaligen
Opfer Regin lof berichtet dass sie auf
diesen Partys den Männern zum Sex
angeboten wurde und das drou auch dabei
war und plötzlich kommen die
Ermittlungen zum
Stillstand jeanm conot der bis dahin
zähe und fleißige Untersuchungsrichter
wird abgezogen und das Justizministerium
beendet alle Untersuchungen zu einem
möglichen
päedophilennetzwerk keine weiteren
Nachforschungen erwünscht ein Skandal
und die Belgier die haben die Nase voll
am 20 oktober 1996 marschiert ein
gigantischer Protestzug von 300.000
Menschen durch Brüssel Belgien steht
kurz vor dem Aufstand das Vertrauen in
die Institution das ist dahin aber ist
diese Empörung gerechtfertigt wir haben
ja eben darüber gesprochen was für ein
organisiertes Netzwerk spricht aber was
spricht denn dagegen es sind vor allem
die Aussagen der Überlebenden Sabine
darden und letizie delhe sie sagen dass
sie in der ganzen Zeit in der sie
entführt worden waren ausschließlich
Mark dtrou zu Gesicht bekommen haben
niemanden sonst und was ebenfalls gegen
ein Netzwerk spricht wären die Taten
dann nicht besser organisiert gewesen
würde jemand der für mächtige
Hintermänner tätig ist mit seinem
eigenen Auto Mädchen entführen wäre das
nicht alles viel anonymer und
professioneller abgelaufen und hätte er
die Mädchen dann nicht zum
verkaufangeboten dazu kommt Mark dou
behauptet zwar Teil eines Netzwerks zu
sein aber mehr Hinweise liefert er nicht
keine Namen keine Adressen keine
Telefonnummern
nichts a Jahre dauert es Mar du Tru und
seine Komplizen vor Gericht zu bringen
was viele Belgier obend drauf noch
stutzig macht in dieser Zeit sterben 27
potenzielle zeugen sie alle kommen unter
verdächtigen Umständen ums Leben das
kann doch alles kein Zufall sein ja wenn
man die ganze Geschichte betrachtet
klingt das schon sehr seltsam im Jahr
2004 dann endlich der Prozess Sabine
daden und Letizia D begegnen ihrem
Peiniger vor Gericht
sie müssen dort noch einmal das
furchtbare Unrecht durchleben das ihnen
angetan wurde am 17 Juni 2004 dann
endlich die Genugtung Mar du Tru wird
wegen vierfachen Mordes Entführung und
Vergewaltigung zu lebenslanger Haft
verurteilt sein Komplize Michelle levre
der den Transporter gefahren hat aus dem
Mark du trou heraus die Mädchen von der
Straße gerissen hat wird wegen
Entführung zu 25 Jahren Haft verurteilt
die TR Frau Michelle martin muss
ebenfalls ins Gefängnis wegen
Verschwörung zur Entführung bekommt sie
30 Jahre
Haft es ist bis heute schwer zu
begreifen was in einem Menschen wie Mark
drou vorgeht aber Reue scheint es ganz
sicher zu keinem Zeitpunkt gewesen zu
sein 2013 mutet er der Öffentlichkeit
noch mal seine geballte Dreistigkeit zu
er beantragt eine vorzeitige
Haftentlassung und damit gehen in den
Fernsehnachrichten noch mal Bilder von
Mark dou um die Welt für Mark du ging es
um eine mögliche vorzeitige
Haftentlassung der belgische
Mädchenmörder hatte dazu jetzt eine
Anhörung vor Gericht D Tru sitzt eine
lebenslange Haftstrafe ab könnte aber
theoretisch dieses Jahr freikommen
praktisch wird das kaum geschehen dazu
hätte auch die Regierung noch ein
Widerspruchsrecht dass ein Verbrecher
wie d trou wieder in Freiheit gelangen
könnte wenn auch mit elektronischer
Fußfessel bewegt Freunde und Verwandte
seiner Opfer aber auch viele Menschen im
ganzen
Land Menschen wie Dru sollten niemals
mehr freikommen sagte Anwalt des Bruders
von einem der toten Mädchen wenn man
wisse was er getan habe und wie er es
getan habe dann sei es für die Regierung
unmöglich jemanden wie du
freizulassen D Tru hatte insgesamt sechs
Mädchen in seiner Gewalt die er folterte
und missbrauchte vier der Mädchen
starben über die Einleitung einer
möglichen Haftentlassung entscheidet das
Gericht nun innerhalb von zwei
Wochen Belgien hält noch mal den Atem an
kommt die Trum mit seiner dreitigkeit
etwa noch mal durch dann die
Erleichterung Brüssel der belgische
kindermördermk du trou bleibt in Haft
ein Brüsseler Gericht lehnte am Montag
seinen Antrag ab mit einer
elektronischen Fußfessel in die Freiheit
zu gelangen eine elektronische Fußfessel
wird Herrn drou nicht gewährt lautet die
Entscheidung die Tru war 2004 zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt worden weil
er sechs Mädchen entführt vergewaltigt
und gefoltert hatte vier von ihnen
starben die Verbrechen hatten das ganze
Land
erschüttert ich glaube damit dass dieser
Mann hinter Gittern bleibt in einer ne
Quadratmeter großen Zelle sind alle
außer die trro auch
einverstanden und hier endet unsere
leider wahre Geschichte vom belgischen
Monster Mar Dru ist aus dem Verkehr
gezogen
für unsere heutige Ausgabe haben wir auf
Beiträge des Spiegel des stern
Ostbelgien direkt und NTV
zurückgegriffen wie immer herzlichen
Dank fürs zuhören und wir freuen uns
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal wieder
mit dabei seid die Kontaktmöglichkeiten
findet ihr in den Show nototes bis dahin
euer Mirko und eure
Tony dir hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
true einfach nicht genug dann hör jetzt
in unsere weiteren Folgen rein hier
warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf
dich wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca
Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder
die Entführung von ursela Hermann wir
hören uns bei Tat Deutschland